so
so
so
so
the senate will come to order
the chaplain will lead the senate in
prayer
let us pray
eternal god
who wraps the ocean
in a cloak
you make the rough places smooth
and the crooked place is straight
as we begin
this 117th
congress
provide our incoming senators with your
wisdom
and direction
lord use them
to transform dark yesterdays
into bright tomorrows
bless all our legislators
with your intervening love
pursue them
with such goodness and mercy
that they will be inspired to tell of
your faithfulness
so that unborn generations
will know
and love you
lord you are our shield
and you
give us victory
we pray
in your marvelous name
amen
please join me in reciting the pledge of
allegiance to our flag
i pledge
allegiance with liberty and justice
it's before the senate the certificates
of election of 32 senators
elected for six-year terms beginning on
january 3 2021.
all certificates the chair is advised
are in the form suggested by the senate
and contain all the essential
requirements of the form suggested by
the senate
if there be no objection the reading of
the certificates will be waived and they
will be printed in the full in the
record
if the senators to be sworn will now
present themselves
at the desk in pairs as their names are
called in alphabetical order
the chair will administer their oaths of
office
the clerk will read the names of the
first pair
mr booker
mrs capito
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge
the duties of the office upon which
you're about to enter so help you god
i do congratulations senator
[Applause]
the clerk will read the names of the
next pair
mr cassidy
ms collins
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
your which you're about to enter so help
you god
congratulations senator
[Applause]
this is the next pair
mr coons
mr cornyn
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you are about to enter so help you
god
congratulations senator
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr cotton mr danes
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
they will bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
i think i do congratulations
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr durbin ms ernst
please raise your right hand do you
solemnly swear that you will support and
defend the constitution of the united
states against all enemies foreign and
domestic
you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
congratulations senator
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr graham mr hagerty
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion and that you will well and
faithfully discharge the duties of the
office upon which you're about to enter
so help you god i did
congratulations senator
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr hickenlooper mrs hyde smith
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion and that you will well and
faithfully discharge the duties of the
office upon which you're about to enter
so help you god
congratulations senator
[Applause]
[Music]
clerk will call the names of the next
pair mr inhofe mr lujan
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
do you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion
and that you well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
i do congratulations senator
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
islamists mr marching
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion
and that you well and faithfully
discharge
the duties of the office upon which
you're about to enter so help you god i
do congratulations senator
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair mr marshall mr mcconnell
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you are about to enter so help you
god
i do
congratulations senator
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr merkley
mr peters
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
i do congratulations senator
[Applause]
clerk will call the names of the next
pair mr reed mr rish
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
do you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
thank you
congratulations
[Applause]
clerk will call the names of the next
pair
mr rounds mr sass
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
do you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office
upon which you're about to enter so help
you god i do i do congratulations
senator
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr shaheen
ms smith
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
do you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr sullivan mr tillis
time
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
i do congratulations senator thank you
[Applause]
the clerk will call the names of the
next pair
mr tuberville mr warner
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
do you bear true faith and allegiance to
the same that you take this obligation
freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
congratulations
[Applause]
majority leader
i suggest the absence of quorum
the absence of a quorum has been
suggested the clerk will call the roll
ms baldwin
mr barrasso
mr bennett
mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr blunt
mr booker
mr bozeman
mr braun
mr brown
mr burr
miss cantwell
mrs cappateau
mr cardin
mr carper
mr casey
mr cassidy
miss collins
mr coons
mr cornyn
miss cortes masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr daines
miss duckworth
mr durbin
ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mrs gillibrand
mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss harris
miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
ms hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
miss klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mrs leffler
mr lujan
miss lumus
mr manchin
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
ms markowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr rish
mr romney
miss rosen
rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
miss smith
miss stabenow
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
miss warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
a quorum is present
majority leader
very briefly i simply want to welcome
all senators on this first day of the
117th congress
today six new members are joining our
ranks for the first time
senators hagerty of tennessee
hickenlooper of colorado lujan of new
mexico
loomis of wyoming marshall of kansas
tuberville of alabama
have been elected to serve the people of
their home states
and of course senator kelly of arizona
was sworn in a few weeks ago
we congratulate all our new colleagues
as well as their families we look
forward to the ways in which their
unique experiences their ideas and their
priorities
will enrich this institution
and strengthen our shared work for the
nation
to say the 117th congress convenes at a
challenging time
would indeed be an understatement
from political division to a deadly
pandemic to adversaries around the world
the hurdles before us are many
and they are serious
but there's also plenty of reason for
hope an optimistic forward-looking
can-do spirit has been one of our
country's most distinctive calling cards
since our very earliest days
and with safe and effective vaccines
rolling out across our nation every day
i'd say 2021
looks bright already
we gavel in today like 116 prior senates
have gaveled in before us
with plenty of disagreements and policy
differences among our ranks
but all all swearing the same oath to
support and defend
the same constitution
all loving
the same country
and all of us committed to do all we can
to leave behind an even stronger nation
than the one we've been blessed
to inherit
so i look forward to the senate's work
these next two years
let's make the american people proud
mr president i ask unanimous consent the
senate proceeded to the consideration of
sres 1 submitted earlier today
the clerk will report the resolution
senate resolution 1 establishing a
committee to inform the president of the
united states that a quorum of each
house is assembled
is there objection to proceeding to the
measure
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure i ask unanimous
consent that the resolution be agreed to
and the motion to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
without objection
pursuant to senate resolution one the
chair appoints the senator from kentucky
mr mcconnell and the senator from new
york mr schumer as a committee to join
the committee on the part of the house
of representatives to wait upon the
president of the united states and
inform him that a quorum is assembled
and that the congress is ready to
receive any communication
he may be pleased to make
as united consent the senate proceeded
to consideration of srs-2 submitted
earlier today
the clerk will report the resolution
senate resolution two informing the
house of representatives that a quorum
of the senate is assembled
is there objection to proceeding to the
measure
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure as unanimous
consent the resolution be agreed to and
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table without
objection as united's consent the senate
proceeded the consideration of srs-3
submitted earlier today
clerk will report
senate resolution 3 fixing the hour of
daily meeting of the
senate is there objection to proceeding
to the measure
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure ask unanimous
consent the resolution be agreed to and
that the motion to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
without objection
ask unanimous consent the senate proceed
to the immediate consideration of s con
res one
the clerk will report
s conrad won concurrent resolution to
provide for the counting on january 6
2021
of the electoral votes for president and
vice president of the united states
is there any objection to proceeding to
the measure
if not
without objections ordered
as unanimous consent can current
resolution be agreed to the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate
without objections ordered as united's
consent the senator proceeded to
immediate consideration of escondress ii
senator waite please
appoints the senator from missouri mr
blunt and the senator from minnesota mr
klobuchar
mrs klobuchar as tellers on the part of
the senate to count the electoral votes
senate majority leader
us united's consent the senate proceeded
to immediate consideration of escond
rest too
the clerk will report
s conrad's two concurrent resolution
extending the life of the joint
congressional committee on inaugural
ceremonies and so forth
is there objection to proceeding to the
measure
without objection so ordered
as united's consent the concurrent
resolution be agreed to the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate
without objections ordered
mr president i send to the desk and
block 11 unanimous consent requests and
i asked for their immediate
consideration in block i further asked
that the requests we agreed to and
blocked the motions to reconsider be
considered made
and laid upon the table and that they
appear separately on the record
before the check before the chair acts
on my request i'd like to point out that
these requests are routine and done at
the beginning of each new congress
[Applause]
is there
objection to
the reading of the resolutions in bloc
yeah and agreeing to the consenting bloc
without objections order
mr president i have a resolution at the
desk
the clerk will report
senate resolution four fixing the hour
of daily meeting of the senate
i ask for it's immediate consideration
and to send the resolution over under
the rule i object to my own request
objection is heard
so the resolution will go over under the
rule
okay under previous order
the leadership's time is reserved
under previous order the senate will be
in a period of morning business with
senators permitted to speak therein for
up to 10 minutes each
senate will be in order
senate majority leader
i understand there's a bill at the desk
and i asked for a first reading
clerk will read the title of the bill
for the first time
s11 a bill to provide for an exception
to a limitation against appointment of
persons as secretary of defense and so
forth
the senate
senate will be in order
senate majority leader i now ask for a
second reading in order to place the
bill on the calendar under the
provisions of rule 14 i object to my own
request
objection haven't been heard
okay colleagues we're about to wrap up
here the the bill will have order in the
senate the bill will receive a second
reading
in the next legislative day
okay
hey uh can we have order in the senate
please
can we have order in the senate please
congratulations
senate majority leader i would just say
to everyone that we're about to go out
of session so it'll be plenty of time
for uh
congratulations and uh
and comments so mr president i ask
unanimous consent that when the senate
completes his business today it adjourn
until 12 30 wednesday january 6th
further following the prayer and pledge
the morning hour redeemed expired the
journal of proceedings be approved to
date
and the time for the two leaders be
reserved their use later in the day
finally following leader remarks the
senate be in a period of morning
business with senators permitted to
speak their input for 10 minutes each
without objection disorder
so there's no further business come for
the senate i stand adjourned under the
previous order
the senate stands in adjournment until
wednesday at 12 30.
so
right
you